time um okay hi everyone what's up
i am super excited to play ratchet and
clan cryptopot
um i've been excited about this game
since it was first revealed i love
insomniac but i think that
technically this game has been just
blowing me away um every step of the way
so i'm really really really really
excited to play it
but uh do want to issue the warning
and i've had really bad allergies all
day so today's the
now is probably the best i've been all
day um so i might sneeze a bit
or have to blow my nose or whatever i'm
gonna do my best
it's uh it's a [ __ ] but
really excited to play rook to pot let's
go
yeah this is my first time playing it um
i have had access to the game since last
night
uh because i'm in australia of course um
but uh wanted to do it live oh my gosh
just trying to make my webcam a little
bit smaller there we go
thank you adil appreciate you thank you
okay
i feel like middle is good
it's so pretty i've been so excited
about this game man and i've not loved
every ratchet game
um i've liked most of them but it's the
tech
it's the tech that gets me to your
nearest
it seems like a thing that would happen
it's beautiful i mean it looks just like
the movie dude
i should put captions on i'll do that
when i can
um edwards playstation australia lent me
an xbox i basically got to sorry a
playstation
i basically got to borrow a company
playstation
i just have to wait till i was out at
the hotel room
where is the infobot
they're pretty scary-looking
thanks cortada where are you going
you know i'm excited about a game when i
start playing and there's just a
permanent like smurf on my face
ah sure i can turn the game up
it looks like it's pretty loud though
okay controller
okay haptic feedback
hey it's okay see
grilled [ __ ]
thank you christopher um i feel like i
just answered that question maybe that's
a delay so no
i did not bring my ps5 to australia it
is too big
uh playstation australia sent me one
being that i'm a sony employee
it's just a company playstation that i'm
able to borrow for the time that i'm
here that i will send back as soon as i
go back home
[Music]
don't you think it's weird to throw a
celebration for us
i mean we haven't done anything heroic
in
years what if everyone thinks we're
washed up oh
what if we are washed up luckily we will
not need to perform any yorkie
unless you count smiling and waving
right this haptic feedback is off the
chain
love it let's see
uh i've worked for sony for nine months
now
um
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no way sony would deny a ps5
when they saw my xbox the companies
don't
believe in the console was the way the
players do
um okay wow i haven't seen these guys in
ages this
is beautiful
hey this is a pretty big turnout
even i was always wondering if there'd
be any frame rate drops but like even
when i'm
jumping into things i'm not supposed to
be sorry this is what i'm doing right
now is checking tech
there was maybe a little bit this is
beautiful
[Music]
balloon ratchet
oh dear must he tell the entire galaxy
wait a gift for what
you will see it is awaiting us at the
front of the parade route
i've always loved his voice performance
just so
restless cute hungry for adventure
this is a very cool way to start a game
i thought that they might all be
breakable i did wanda
excuse me i must break all boxes also
particles
it's very cool very very into it
[Music]
okay
the controller is on one it's great
they sure pulled out oh welcome someone
awesome games what's up
flattering
[Music]
all right
the amount of just like stuff on screen
right now though
my god
and maybe i shouldn't have streamed this
i'm just like
i will perceive everything and i will
not say anything it's gonna be great
no that was an explosive my apologies i
apologize for that
but i want to shoot the explosies
very nice
i don't know troy's probably in it
somewhere statistically
[Music]
i'm wondering if like okay so this isn't
i'm i
obviously i don't want to kill anyone i
just want to see how far this shot goes
i mean as far as you can see but it
doesn't
impact upon anything uh what did you
want me to do shoot
the blog ships
what is this supposed to be a
re-enactment
[Applause]
[Music]
ratchet i do not believe this is part of
the show
the um i remember them talking about
this in one of the like state of plays
or something the um
press square to a freeload but they
didn't need to the the way that the
trigger changes
uh fire rates i believe is what's
happening
kind of like return someone put a bounty
on
us thanks amy thank you i am very happy
having a great time
um yeah i'm playing in performance mode
people asking hurry we must get to the
front but uh
oh but i but i want to break them
they break anyway um youtube compression
really does break everything when you're
live streaming you tend to look better
when it's
when it's actually uploaded after the
live stream cool
get dunked on mate
no
[Music]
yes
god this is so pleasant let me hit you
let me smack you about oh their
animation that was needed
shook the ui when they hit me i kind of
want to do that again i would like to
see that animation again please
somebody attacked me no no nothing not
the guns it's got to be a mealy
bring back robo dog i'm not positive
that's what i saw
i should be breaking more [ __ ] i really
feel like i should it's fine it's fine
it's fine you can enjoy the game you
don't have to do everything on play
through one
this is nuts
how about you say
it shouldn't work i don't know if it
does but it shouldn't
[Music]
it broke my cover i don't know you could
do that oh it's floaty
[Music]
this is beautiful what the hell
so yeah i believe this game has ray
tracing on both modes actually
um but in any case this is totally has
ray tracing right now what we're seeing
is the rays being traced and it is
i don't beautiful if i do
dude there's just like so much
density look at you go ps5
[Music]
i'm not sure what happens if i get up
close to these guys how useful is wrench
turns out
wrench pretty good yeah hit me somebody
hit me
it does it makes the ui wobble i love
that very good
that's
[Music]
i awesome i don't know what i've been
playing that's making me
automatically hit the reload button
maybe annie shooter
i don't know why i keep going try it
must hit square
not today [ __ ]
oh i thought i was gonna jump in that is
my bag
[Music]
this is so sweet
[Music]
it might be i'm not sure if she wants to
be lighted
um yeah the haptic feedback is great um
i found it like very odd when i first
started playing
ps5 games and i was kind of like one of
god by i kind of sometimes a little bit
too distracting but
i had a speech i really liked it but
considering that our event seems to be
under assault
i will cut to the chase ratchet i do not
know where i would be without you
you are my closest friend my teammate
and you have given up a lot too i ran
out of tissues
so you can travel through dimensions and
find your family
no pal i
[Music]
considering my tones were meant to
annihilate you
eight minutes ago oh what do you
want nefarious yes
i'm so excited to actually be getting to
play these sections
i wonder how disorienting it will be
i'm playing the game and i'm just like
excited about playing the game
love video games man what a what a
medium what a great medium
it's also just nuts that the gameplay
looks just as pixel movie as these
cutscenes do
my god
i want that ratchet as a doll it's so
cute
oh look at his little face
i don't know wow it's been
ripped apart
i'm here all day ooh
okay what are we gonna do here
also i wonder if they can keep this pace
up this is action-packed
you want me to run across this okay from
dr
[Music]
good
you're still here
yes there really is no difference
between aside from the camera
oh is that ammo down wait perhaps we can
put quartz pyrotechnics to use
[Music]
nice
[Music]
i should have known nefarious would try
something like this
don't beat yourself up this'll be just
like old times
come on it looks like nefarious landed
somewhere near the train station
go mrs zircon we should grab a weapon
need a weapon mrs zircon has it all oh
god i love her
look how cool she is also just
these [ __ ] environments man i'm gonna
spend so much time just looking at stuff
in this game
beautiful absolutely beautiful
okay
so many comments about being upside down
since i got to australia
sadly never gets old never
never castle but um you know now i'm
playing ratchet and clank i can be
upside down
there's the rules okay
can i afford both of these probably not
i
cannot
i think i want to do that one oh i see
that's better
throwing them with your bare freaking
hands
pull the fire trigger halfway to
visualize your
aim or if you are in a hurry
pull it all the way now let
it's so cool that that's like part of
tutorialization now
i don't know what i expected okay i'm
gonna watch all of these
[Music]
[Laughter]
one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god i want you to to sell me
everything i've ever sold for the rest
of my life please
like i'm gonna go buy some toothpaste
and
you're gonna be like and if you don't
want
cavities i'm gonna be like yes
all of it oh my god there is a dog
outside the door give me a second i
gotta let her in
otherwise she'll just cry it's hot it's
hard being away from me i get it
you don't get any attention out there
let me do it
drop my controller
blood dragon tutorial what's the dog's
name uh her name is ebony
she is lovely but she does love
attention she's a very needy dog
um okay
i'm gonna go with the shadow bomb
thank you and i cannot afford that right
yeah
sweet because it reminds me of quake
okay do i have it equipped
oh i see
quite good actually it's the easiest to
use grenade ever
i like it it's good i would actually
probably use that forever by choice
because
it makes me feel like a wizard
nope stop trying to reload elana you
keep trying to do it
it is not necessary oh did i have to get
on that train is that gonna be a problem
excuse me i'm just breaking [ __ ] don't
mind me
that was quite seamless put down the
dimensionator nefarious
put down the dimensionator yeah
right today you will see what losing
feels like
spider it's exhausting
as soon as i figure out these stupid
coordinates
say goodbye
[Music]
what did you
did we cause the chaos
hello hello friends oh my gosh
what just happened we may have a slight
problem the bridge is shot
there has to be another way across hmm
let's do it
let's go to the face quartz in your
glove
try pointing it at one of them
i already said i'm playing on
performance mode
or at least i'm bringing ram shows last
night
i'm assuming it keeps gonna come in
handy
very cool that's so seamless
it's a nice little teleport mechanic
i wonder how much nefarious is paying
these guys
not nearly enough
oh that's what i was trying to do is get
my shadow ball back out
this thing is nate nice present
[Applause]
oh my okay what's that going to be
something else is going to show up
it's dinosaurs all right
hell yeah whoa watch your head
this is worse than i had imagined
very cool
i would like to go with you
[Music]
hey little guys what y'all doing
they're very easy to take out with that
shadow bomb it is wonderful what a
weapon what a weapon
should i be breaking those stuff
[Applause]
or at least a very large octopus
so creative
[Applause]
nefarious ship we've got to find a way
up there
the taxis leaving from that stand are
driving right by him then we can better
not miss our ride
we're going to go get a taxi is what
we're doing right now ratchet okay
when did you rebuild the dimension i
have
hobbies and i know that finding the
lombaxes has always been important to
you
i thought perhaps we could go or
together
no it doesn't matter it's a teleporter
really thoughtful
but i thank you
sorry about that mate i didn't mean to
upset
[Music]
i'm just going to go
[Music]
our rides here goddamn pump
i feel like i should be doing more
exploring but
next stop nefarious not yet oh i can
still move
these rifts are getting out of hand oh
my god
it's so exciting
[Music]
i remember seeing this whole other stuff
like i think it's this segment that we
saw
one of the earlier gameplay
thank you dorian thanks so much
i'm a big fan of the shadow bomb even if
i probably should be using the aim thing
where i'm frequently not
why not you know why not
[Music]
i was sort of expecting that
okay
just again why not hang on they're going
to be slightly further away
it's very cool hey guys sorry about what
i did here
at home sorry about all that
nice work ratchet thank you pal
all right now let's get to nefarious
and this will be it game will be over no
worries it's done it would be great
quickly we cannot let nefarious overuse
the dimensionator
we must lower his defenses
[Music]
not tremendously but
nope mess it up again wait tell me the
various
oh maybe that oh that's that oh oh
that's way more of a jump than i thought
it was
oh oh oh that's easy my bad i thought
that it was just like gonna be like a
little
side hop oh
okay that's why the timing is different
can i go through one of them
those are all right now they are pretty
bad actually they keep killing frogs out
here in australia
it's a real problem that's what we get
on the news in australia
toads are killing frogs
my parts around here
love that ui wobble that makes me okay
with being hooked
so cute oh hello
gonna take a little while to get used to
that i reckon but it's very fun i wanna
have free put those uh yellow photos
actually off
how often do you actually see them oh my
you did it too fast
they're still even in the middle of a
boss fight where i'm having rockets shot
at me there's still cars and [ __ ] moving
in the background
beautiful videos
we're going to a dimension where i
always win
so you can finally know how it feels
are you okay buddy i feel like you need
some bear
let's do it i'm so ready
this place is cool
[Music]
how bad is it
[Music]
well it is certainly not good no could
we stay in this one
now i have a mountain
oh my god
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] this is cool
off me ship really i was so certain
they'd explode oh okay it was just time
did i do it oh what is this
what's with all the neon this is the
part
where you lose
ratchet the dimension hater
that seems bad i feel like that's
probably possibly a negative
uh jake the orange portals don't
actually take you to a different
dimension
they're just it's just like warping in
the same dimension
and no it's just like a tether
teleporter what have i done
what have you done who are you
someone with a lot of questions
let's go for a ride yeah wait
i have to find out i just steal a
stranger like that girl [ __ ]
my god
[Music]
i'm happy for you buddy i really am
nefarious you have returned early from
your conquest
yes emperor
[Laughter]
hell yeah i'm i'm very happy
it's my current take i'm happy to be
here
it's gotta suck though the only way you
can be successful is if you like
literally find an intimate
interdimensional portal
that's some heavy [ __ ] that is
quite the elf
what is this place
it's just so pretty
where are you clank maybe someone around
here has seen him
my god
hello who is
oh i love it
what are you guys up to i'm looking at
the trash tv
it just says seven it's gonna say seven
forever i promise
that lighting though bam
have any of you seen a little grey robot
anywhere no he got stolen dude
complete stranger he basically got
abducted he got like child of double
and it was pretty [ __ ] up i am not on
her side
keep women out of video games
case in point you know
i just keep wanting to look at
everything you know
this whole [ __ ] game is a gallery
are you okay me
are you in pain are you having an orgasm
either way i'll leave you to it
good day good day i said good day
but first we look around
this i mean this definitely does feel
next-gen to me
extremely
welcome video games didn't look like
this recently oh my god
it does right that's why he said maybe
he's in this bazaar
that's why his assistant said you're
back early
um no i'm not going to turn up the
brightness i don't want to i don't want
to
but to me it looks perfect so i i
wouldn't want to wash it out
because it's so pretty
hello
oh my god i love them all so much with
my whole heart hmm
i see that you want me to go there but
is that where i'm supposed to go right
now
can i do this
okay and then
was that maybe um a walrus situation i
thought that was just l2
but my guess is that maybe i need uh
some kind of different sort of boot
something upgrade thingamabob
look at it video games
wow beautiful
oh i remember her too where is she who
just said hey long backs
wait a second she's very cool she is
very
you cool but you gotta be less
conspicuous
or the resistance will not last
the resistance hmm
political themes in my video games
i'm really on one with this lately all
video games are political
no i need to go after that ship
how can i get off planet it's a test
only royal starships are allowed to
leave
anything else
phantom can help just follow the bait to
club nefarious and you will find him
club nefarious got it oh and nice work
secret agent zircon
this is so exciting oh my god i love
everyone and everything
is gonna sound it's killing me i would
like to go to wherever this club is
though you hear that
where's the club at we're actually
trying to get lit
i always get excited when i like in-game
music because i'm like oh there's a new
dr nefarious so what happened
wall climb buddy you only jump once for
now
so many level-ups to do
hello my cute friend who
is broadcasting all of this [ __ ] the
sooner i find club nefarious and this
yes yes sounds like a club all right
oh it is i'm going in the direction of
the club anyway wonderful oh look at it
oh my god what wow
ah
[ __ ] i've got i just i just really
love video games
you know i just think video games
are really good just what a medium
[Applause]
am i really allowed
oh thank you dorian thank you so much
that's exactly how i feel edward when
there's a really good ost it's on
spotify it's
heartbreaking hi yeah are you the
phantom
where's the dj at play taylor swift
did you play beyonce honestly when i was
a dj which i
i guess it's not that i'm not i just
haven't and well last one was like
december
no it's february it's bright spots um
the most
common requests are white girls
requesting taylor swift and beyonce
all right
i just don't feel like he'd be a very
good ruler you know
battlefield 2042 was cheaper oh i wonder
what they have to do
i paid 124 for this game
australia
and i was like oh my gosh i forgot how
expensive games are here 124 dollars
better take care of these guys or
they'll go after phantom two devastated
that the club is over
i thought i was about to get lit phantom
right have a couple of white clothes
trying to be bros
maybe in this universe you are oh is it
because she is
is it because girl chit yes i know his
name is ribbit but i like calling her
girl [ __ ] more
ah yes good
this game feels fantastic to play
i didn't end up reading the reviews i
know it was like loudly like nines and
eights
um i don't want to read them because you
know i'm very happy to be playing this
game and i don't want to think about any
negatives
until they occur to me
but the only thing that has really
occurred to me is that like maybe it
could be they could drag this out it
could be too long
that's based on nothing so far this is
wonderful
there's only so much you can do with
this
everything is okay um
no i just said i bought it i did not get
the game free from tony
phantom i spent 125 dollars on it
i bought my ps4 i mean my ps5 i buy all
my
ps5 games
okay
neat
i would like to see that get more
elaborate and i say that as someone
who's very bad at platforming
hey wait oh i did that wrong
i have to double tap it faster
hey wait
did it just send me forward because i
felt i think that happened last time too
oh my god my nose is so
[Music]
it really does like obliterate their
entire bodies
i do really like this side jump
it's like very lofty
[Music]
all these robots are you guys all okay
thank you
seem like you're all really [ __ ]
miserable man and oh
what is this some kind of
you guys on a date are you arguing are
you
what's the context just kind of bumping
uglies
okay i'm sorry i tried to get involved
that's okay
i can't actually do it if i'm not locked
on something so it has to be like that
is the way that you do the the side jump
which is wonderful it just feels really
good and i really like that animation
oh that was an accident oops thanks
what is this some kind of secret
handshake
hey we're doing
oh this we started gameplay too and i
was like what the hell is this
[ __ ] this game's cool very on board
okay
he now that he's talking more he's
progressively becoming less cool
you gotta jump and then phantom dash
very nice thank you
i'm not great at while running in any
video game it's a thing
um yes ivan i am still at home i'm at my
mom's place
don't be scared use the glove to run
along those panels
that's what that one before was there
for jump and phantom dash
that's what i like to see i need a royal
starship to find my friend
i heard you know where to get one it's
not safe
just stay close i mean you're yelling
about everything else i feel like we're
all right
are just as stubborn as she is wait you
know that other lombax
where did she go sardasa she always goes
there after a mission
sargasso
oh man edward i would love a jet post
gemini sequel
i don't think ratchet and deathless
gemini are that similar because i feel
like jeff was gemini is a bit more of a
traditional shooter
no it's not really in any case i love
those games i like ratchet for different
reasons um
and again have like i don't think i've
played all of them but
so i wouldn't say i'm generally like an
enormous fan of this franchise but
i've been really really excited about
this game specifically i did play the
last one and really liked it
um so yeah i'm um
very happy to be playing this one but
damn i would love more jeffers gemini
too
i'll make you a deal you see that blimp
yeah what's up with that
you help me take control of it and i'll
help you
get into nefarious towers oh cool it's
the only place in the city you're gonna
find a royal starship
what's so special about the blind just
find a way up to that rooftop
i gotta grab my gear but i'll meet you
up there
okay let's do it how do i get to that
rooftop
i'm coming clank it is very easy to tell
where it's supposed to go to and in a
world that like
is this busy right that looks this open
stage they do a very good job of you
know even when i've been exploring i'm
like what is this robot doing i know
exactly the direction that i'm supposed
to head in
um shout out to the level design team
for that because
that stuff ain't easy are you gonna
attack me
[Music]
yes
yeah it's got to be kind of difficult to
make something very busy
also um
very easy to follow
the people who work in triple-a game
development i mean you know
across the board are just so incredibly
talented
at what they do just the best in the
world at skills that other people do not
have
and it is wonderful and a blessing
i'm sorry you guys i never mean to upset
the sad robots among us
i'm really sorry about all of that
[Music]
that's gonna be an l1 i just missed it
oh i hit r1 instead
oh let me uh turn on
well while we're here i can do photo
mode
just give you a quick look at it
orbit
could get some real pretty photos
through this
neat
it's goddamn beautiful okay i want to
change that focus distance for sure
i'm not clear on where it's going
there that's what i wanted the neo focus
assistance
hmm
i kind of like the sound as strange as
it is i kind of like it
filter type
why is it oh it's going back to normal
in between that's interesting
mmm that's neat damn you could like
fully
make like a noir comic
high action
very good
oh vignette intensity huh nice i mean
this is a terrible picture for the
record i'm not saving this this is bad
but uh gives you an idea of what the
photo mode looks like
yeah make it grainy
very customizable as it turns out who'd
have thought
but um i've made trash so i do not
intend to keep this
but it does look awesome
yes uh what was i going to do oh yeah
uh no we want to go to options
uh yeah oh okay it wants me to look at
the map now
which i don't know i tend to try to
avoid
which may be a bad idea but um
[Music]
let me see settings
subtitles
oh that's interesting on
i'll go large so everybody can see
cool hopefully
that's saved beautiful
oh i could have made that so much
smoother damn it
alana that's on me i'm really bad at the
i'm platforming it's a problem
okay
yeah he's a real gamer alice
are you headed to the room you should
use that raritanium in your pocket to
upgrade your arsenal okay
this is so much stuff oh my okay
you are getting it special upgrades
purchase all upgrades connected to a
gold cell cluster okay that makes sense
shots go further upgrading your loadout
is not hard
as long as you've got the raritanium hmm
that's cool
okay which is all upgrades connect the
gold cell is that just everything
are they all max ammo
kind of looks like they are
see why settle for a good weapon
pretty simple
okay
always worth the calls to keep your
weapons in tip-top shape
the area of effect is probably the most
useful one um
i'm not really concerned about the speed
but
why not for now treat yourself to an
upgrade
you earned it thank you we have already
done most of this though the pixelizer
hmm that's neat
i don't know i'm good for now um okay
topiary sprinkler
i'm gonna watch all these
with the previews press of a button and
it is called
a negatron
[Music]
obliterator oh it's so cute
who has okay little zircon's enemies
and performed at his last birthday party
mr fun died
just throw him out and he will strike
your enemies so hard
[Music]
i was like there's not gonna be one for
that um okay can i upgrade anything else
purchase all hmm i can't afford that
i'm just not really sure what i want to
do yet is my is sort of my problem i
don't know
let's do that one is so
hot right now i think i'm gonna do this
yeah i can just afford it and it looks
cool as [ __ ]
and then he may be upgraded to collider
that seems like it'll be helpful for
this one right
chain select oh that's cool so it
expects me to be able to upgrade
everything i'm trying to be conservative
because i'm like i don't know what i'm
gonna get yet but
realistically probably don't have to
worry about any of that
um first pistol i was happy with what we
got anyway it's all just [ __ ] max
ammo
cool good with me thanks again for the
help secret agent
thank you madame was never here
oh my god
okay um i'll probably stop playing
pretty soon on youtube and jump over to
twitch
until my mom gets home wait you can see
me
where are you you got my starship ready
you'll get it don't you worry i just
need you to help me with one last threat
the nefarious day spa very threatening
it makes sense i'll hack the fairies as
propaganda blimp and give this city
thanks also good day from brizzy i'm
actually not in brisbane but close
looks easy enough
[Music]
it's gonna hurt me that's my answer
i suspected as much
okay
cool way to do that okay what do you
want me to do here
it is quite good and yeah i don't
i think they're probably having that
beam charged a little bit faster is a
good thing to level up
what are you all doing i'm also not sure
if there's a fossil way to change
weapons than this
just tapping doesn't seem to work
take shadow bombs
[Music]
hold on
thank you cute
that is a really good system
the um the holes to like get your off
and then stroller
you guys going up here then i'm going
down there all the way around i mean
oh no you came
get out of here
i'm gonna go back to my collider
and get two of you at once i think
that's how it works
yeah it does that is awesome that is
cool as hell
[Music]
uh we haven't used this so let's do the
pixel either
very cool
oh it doesn't have like a half trigger
we need to upgrade it for that
this is basically a shotgun
what was he talking about nefarious
tower here i come
up bro you're right we are out here what
did you learn
looks like i touched a nerve all right
deal's a deal
that's glitch she'll help you get out to
the emperor's private shuttle
access consoles in that huge statue of
nefarious in the center of the city
just hook her up and she'll handle the
rest
what are you doing tearing this whole
rotten world
down from the inside he's [ __ ] cool
man that dude [ __ ] for sure
no doubt oh i don't know can you use
directional buttons i should
should have given that a shot it would
make sense i was sure there would be
some way to do it faster than pressing
um
you are correct look at that animation
all right ratchet okay
it's like i'm playing a fighting game
um all right everyone thank you for
joining me for the start of the game i
like to do these streams just like give
people who haven't had access to it an
idea of the start of the game or what it
looks like without any spoilers but i'm
going to jump over to twitch now
um i will stream over there until my mom
gets home so we can hang out
the sun's also going to go down sword
and it's 3 20 we're fine
um that'll take me like a little bit to
change my settings for the stream but um
yeah i'll be on twitch thank you for
joining me
and uh i will see you over there
i'm gonna play more of it i'm very
excited very happy to be playing it
that's what's up